Psychologists are improving more than people's mental health. Obesity, smoking, heart disease, all of these physical health problems often involve behavior. In this episode, Dr. Norman Anderson, CEO of the American Psychological Association, explains how psychologists play an essential role on health care teams alongside physicians and other medical professionals. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology. Today we are talking to Dr. Norman Anderson. Dr. Anderson is the CEO of the American Psychicons. Psychological Association and the Director of the Association Center for Psychology and Health. As our nation strives to improve health outcomes for all Americans, the APA and its Center for
心理学家们改善的不仅仅是人们的心理健康。肥胖、吸烟、心脏病，所有这些身体健康问题往往都与行为有关。在本期节目中，美国心理学会首席执行官诺曼·安德森博士将解释心理学家如何与医生及其他医疗专业人员一起，在医疗团队中发挥至关重要的作用。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这里是《心理学谈话》。今天我们采访的是诺曼·安德森博士。安德森博士是美国心理学会的首席执行官，也是该协会心理学与健康中心的主任。随着我国努力改善所有美国人的健康状况，美国心理学会及其中心正在
Psychology and Health are working to expand psychology's role in health by improving access to psychological and behavioral health services, particularly in primary care settings. Welcome, Dr. Anderson. Thank you. Good to be here. Dr. Anderson, could you explain in more detail the reasons for creating the APA Center for psychology and health? Well, we have a strategic plan in APA, and one of the goals in the strategic plan is to advance psychology's role in improving the nation's health. Most people
心理学与健康中心致力于通过改善心理和行为健康服务的获取途径，特别是在初级保健环境中，来扩大心理学在健康领域的作用。欢迎您，安德森博士。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。安德森博士，您能更详细地解释一下创建美国心理学会心理学与健康中心的原因吗？嗯，我们在美国心理学会有一个战略计划，该计划的目标之一就是提升心理学在改善国民健康方面的作用。大多数人
understand that psychology and psychologists have a role in improving mental health, things like depression and anxiety, but they don't really understand that we have a very important contribution to make in improving overall health, even physical health. Our research has shown very clearly that behavioral and psychological factors contribute greatly to things like heart disease, the course of cancer, HIV, AIDS, diabetes. So we have a very important role to play in overall health, not just mental health. So the Center for Psychology and Health was created to really galvanize the resources we have within the central office to to advance this overall goal in health.
理解心理学和心理学家在改善心理健康（如抑郁和焦虑）方面发挥作用，但他们并不真正了解我们在改善整体健康，甚至是身体健康方面可以做出非常重要的贡献。我们的研究非常清楚地表明，行为和心理因素对心脏病、癌症病程、艾滋病、糖尿病等疾病有很大影响。因此，我们在整体健康方面发挥着非常重要的作用，而不仅仅是在心理健康方面。所以，心理学与健康中心的成立，是为了真正整合我们在总部拥有的资源，以推进这一整体健康目标。
One of the goals of the Affordable Health Care Act is to have integrated health care teams. Can you tell us what those are and why they're important? Integrated healthcare teams are very important in improving the overall health of patients. Because we know that all health problems are multifaceted, they involve biological factors, psychosocial factors, behavioral factors, it's really important that you have the right mix of professionals working with patients on their health problems. For example, it's important that physicians work hand in hand with psychologists or other mental health professionals with nurses, with people from physical therapy, from a whole host
《平价医疗法案》的目标之一是建立综合医疗团队。您能告诉我们这些团队是什么，以及为什么它们很重要吗？综合医疗团队对于改善患者的整体健康非常重要。因为我们知道所有的健康问题都是多方面的，它们涉及生物因素、社会心理因素和行为因素，所以让合适的专业人员组合与患者合作解决他们的健康问题非常重要。例如，医生与心理学家或其他心理健康专业人员、护士、物理治疗师以及来自各行各业的人员携手合作，
of disciplines to really serve the whole patient, to meet the whole patient's health care needs. And research is beginning to show that when you do take this whole person approach to health, outcomes actually improve and there can be some cost savings. What kinds of behaviors are associated with disease? I mean, how exactly can a psychologist help treat disease? Well, in multiple ways. For example, at the most basic level, physicians are not really trained unless they trained in psychiatry to address mental health problems or to treat mental health problems.
共同服务于患者，满足患者的整体医疗需求，这一点非常重要。研究开始表明，当你采取这种全人健康方法时，治疗效果确实会改善，并且可以节省一些成本。哪些行为与疾病有关？我的意思是，心理学家究竟如何帮助治疗疾病？嗯，通过多种方式。例如，在最基本的层面上，医生除非受过精神病学培训，否则并没有真正接受过解决心理健康问题或治疗心理健康问题的培训。
So it's very important that those mental health problems get addressed in primary care. Primary care is really on the front lines of health care. So it's really important to have that mental health component available for patients right there within primary care. But beyond mental health care is very important that you have professionals like psychologists available to address health behaviors more generally. Things like diet, smoking, exercise, but also things like psychological stress, which is a major contributor to the course of illness. Essentially, behavioral and social factors contribute to health and illness across the whole continuum from the initiation of diseases. For example, stress can actually change biology in ways to lead to a greater propensity to
因此，在初级保健中解决这些心理健康问题非常重要。初级保健确实处于医疗保健的最前线。因此，在初级保健中为患者提供心理健康服务非常重要。但除了心理健康护理之外，拥有像心理学家这样的专业人员来更广泛地解决健康行为问题也非常重要。比如饮食、吸烟、运动，还有心理压力，这是导致疾病病程的主要因素。从本质上讲，行为和社会因素在疾病发生的整个过程中都会影响健康和疾病。例如，压力实际上可以改变生物学机制，从而导致更大的倾向性，进而
develop certain health problems. These same factors can be used to prevent health problems, such as helping a person develop more healthy lifestyle habits, such as quitting smoking, losing weight, can actually help prevent illnesses. But also if a person has an illness like heart disease, certain factors like depression and stress can actually accelerate the course of their arteries, including, that is getting clogged, and lead to a heart attack. So throughout the whole continuum of illness, behavioral and social factors are important, and they have to be addressed. What is on the 2014 agenda for the Center for Psychology and Health?
引发某些健康问题。这些相同的因素也可以用来预防健康问题，例如帮助一个人养成更健康的生活习惯，如戒烟、减肥，实际上可以帮助预防疾病。但如果一个人已经患有心脏病，抑郁和压力等某些因素实际上会加速动脉病程，包括动脉阻塞，并导致心脏病发作。因此，在整个疾病过程中，行为和社会因素都很重要，必须加以解决。2014年心理学与健康中心的工作议程是什么？
Well, the Center works in four primary areas. We work on advocacy, education and training of psychologists, communicating, with our members and the public and outreach to other organizations. And so we've got things playing in each of those areas. For example, with advocacy, we're working to ensure that financing is available to help foster some of these integrated care teams that I spoke about earlier. Right now, we really don't have good models to give the public access to these teams. So we're working with various organizations to help create those models.
嗯，该中心在四个主要领域开展工作。我们致力于倡导、心理学家的教育和培训、与我们的成员和公众沟通，以及与其他组织的联络。因此，我们在每个领域都有相应的计划。例如，在倡导方面，我们正在努力确保有资金支持，以帮助促进我之前提到的那些综合护理团队的发展。目前，我们确实没有好的模式让公众能够接触到这些团队。因此，我们正在与各组织合作，帮助创建这些模式。
It's also very important that we communicate with psychologists about the importance of learning about participating in integrated care teams and in primary care. Most psychologists, frankly, weren't trained in this field, so we have to educate our own profession about the importance of this and provide training tools to help them get up to speed so they can participate as professionals. You know, one example of this is we have something called a briefing sheet series, which we are doing in collaboration with our interdivisional health care coalition. These are divisions of APA who are interested in health who have been really helpful to us in putting together fact sheets, briefing sheets that we call them on various aspects of health, such as psychologists working in primary care, psychologists working on the problem of chronic cancer. pain in obesity. So this is sort of a first level of education for psychologists to get a brief one-page overview of how psychologists contribute to preventing or treating some of these so-called physical health problems. We also use those briefing sheets to help create content for our website so they can be found there. And frankly, this type of podcast series,
与心理学家沟通了解参与综合护理团队和初级保健的重要性也非常重要。坦率地说，大多数心理学家并没有在这个领域接受过培训，所以我们必须教育我们自己的专业人员了解其重要性，并提供培训工具帮助他们跟上进度，以便他们能以专业人员的身份参与其中。你知道，这方面的一个例子是我们有一个所谓的简报系列，这是我们与跨部门医疗保健联盟合作完成的。这些是美国心理学会中对健康感兴趣的分支机构，他们在整理事实清单、简报（我们称之为简报）方面对我们非常有帮助，内容涵盖健康的各个方面，例如心理学家在初级保健中的工作、心理学家在慢性疼痛和肥胖问题上的工作。所以，这对于心理学家来说是一种初步的教育，让他们能简要地了解心理学家如何为预防或治疗这些所谓的身体健康问题做出贡献。我们还利用这些简报来帮助创建我们网站的内容，以便在那里可以找到它们。坦率地说，这种播客系列，
We will use those briefing sheets as a context to bring in psychologists who are experts in things like chronic pain to share that information with our members and the public as well. Well, thank you, Dr. Anderson, for joining us. I appreciate it. My pleasure. Thank you. For more information about the Center for Psychology and Health, visit our website at speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association, speaking of psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们将利用这些简报作为背景，邀请慢性疼痛等领域的心理学家专家，与我们的成员和公众分享这些信息。好的，谢谢安德森博士加入我们。我很感激。不客气。谢谢。有关心理学与健康中心的更多信息，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。这里是美国心理学会的《心理学谈话》，我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。